sur ce qui s'est passé hier avec les
témoins de cet attentat dont le
principal témoin hier soir aux alentours
de 19h un homme a ouvert le feu dans une
rue du centreville de Bruxelles il a
dans un premier temps tiré dans le H
d'immeuble puis il a tiré sur un taxi
[Musique]
regardez
il visait donc des supporters suédois
ces derniers portaient des maillots à
l'occasion du match éliminatoire de
l'euro Belgique
Suède les deux hommes visés âgés d'une
soixantaine d'années sont décédés malgré
les tentatives des secours pour les
sauver je vrais remercier Souleiman qui
est avec nous merci beaucoup d'être là à
vous vous avez croisé la route de la
Saillon hier vous êtes le principal
vraiment témoin et on a Caroline qui est
avec nous bonjour Caroline ça va bien et
c'est votre fille oui exactement c'est
Yelena merci merci d'être là vous étiez
présente au match Belgique Suède vous
êtes de la famille de de joueurs oui
tout à fait épou j'aimis beaucoup
joueurs j'aime beaucoup joueurs c'est
pour ça merci vous êtes sa sa femme oui
ah bah très bien bah vous avez très bien
choisi j'adore ce jou c'est un grand
joueur non mais c'est vrai voilà vous
l'embrasserez de ma part en tout cas je
le ferai merci comment vous avez appris
ce qui ce qui s'est passé parce que vous
vous étiez dans le stade c'est ça voilà
nous on était dans le stade donc au
moment où on rejoignait la tribune mon
mari a reçu une notification euh d'un
d'un journal sur son téléphone mais au
début on parlait pas d'attentat on a vu
fusillade à Bruxelles donc on s'est pas
vraiment inquiété on est monté dans la
tribune on a pris place et ensuite le
match a commencé et là c'est j'ai reçu
des messages sur messenger une amie une
amie belge du Portugal qui m'a envoyaé
des des des messages mais que je pouvais
pas ouvrir à cause des réseaux qui
étaient saturés et elle me disait partez
partez et donc ensuite j'ai Yelena qui
m'a appelé et qui m'a dit maman Yelena
n'était pas avec vous en plus non elle
était à la maison en fait donc elle elle
suivait tout de la maison et vous rendez
compte pour des parents vous étiez avec
votre mari au match ça dû être
l'angoisse absolue exactement qu'est-ce
que ça a été quoi votre réaction vous
êtes pas dit je vais rentrer je vais
essayer mais impossible pas du tout en
fait parce qu'en fait au départ on était
pas du tout inquiet tout se passait bien
le match avait commencé et en fait moi
j'avais Yelena qui me disait maman
attention il y a un terroriste qui se
dirige vers le stade et moi en fait en
voyant les mesures de sécurité qui sont
prises pour rentrer dans le stade je
pouvais pas imaginer qu'on était allit
qu'on soit en danger en fait c'était pas
possible justementena toi tu étais toute
seule à la maison moi j'étais toute
seule à la maisonas D flipper grave moi
ça m'énervait que il s'inquiète pas plus
parce que moi la prochaine fois tu
m'app c'est vrai que mais parce que moi
j'aurais été très stressé ah ou comends
parce que eux en fait ils se rendaient
pas compte du drame qui se passait et
donc toi tu étais toute seule à la
maison qu'est-ce que cétait quoi ta
raction mais moi donc en fait ma
meilleure amie m'appelle et elle me dit
oui il y a eu un attentat j'ai j'étais
je suis restée 40 minutes en classe en
plus on pouvait pas sortir de l'école et
j'ai dit comment ça il me dit oui j'ai
parlé avec le monsieur de la sécurité et
elle me dit donc il y a il y a eu un un
homme qui a tiré à à à l'entrée du métro
de iszer et donc et sur deux suéois et
donc
elle me dit et apparemment il se dirige
vers le stade de foot je dis mais
comment tu sais ça elle me dit il a mis
une vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux donc
moi je vais sur Twitter je vais regarder
la vidéo vous avez vu donc le
l'assaillant oui j'ai vu ça avec vous
avez vu sa vidéo qu'on a tous vu ici
également et donc et donc là vous dites
quoi donc là moi je stresse je pense
direct à mes parents donc j'appelle ma
maman qui me répond pas parce qu'il y a
pas de réseau donc je suis encore plus
stressée je lui envoie plein de messages
et elle me dit ah
t'inquiète ça va elle se rendait pas
compte je pense non et moi je stressais
parce que en fait on voyait plein de
vidéos sur les réseaux
sociaux qui de la son qui se baladait
dans Bruxelles et moi j'avais peur qu'à
tout moment ils viennent au stade bien
sûr bah oui même même toi toute seule à
la maison qu'est-ce que tu as fait tu
t'es barricadé tu t'es dit j'ai pris le
chien avec moi ah ou vous AZ pris le
chien j'ai pris le chien ouais et et
donc non tu as dû tu as dû vraiment
flipper de fou tu appelis tes copines tu
appelis tout le monde tu essayis d'avoir
quelqu'un appelis quelqu'un toujours et
je pouvais pas dormir justement au match
euh parce que forcément vous avez dû
penser aux attentats aux abords du Stade
de France en 2015 est-ce que vous avez
senti un un moment quand même une vague
d'inquiétude dans le stade ou pas du
tout et bien euh pas du tout en fait c
c'est ça qui en fait on av vent les
supporters chantai tout ça les
supporters chantai faisaiit laa je veux
dire allez je veux dire et c'est pour ça
que nous on comprenait pas allez je veux
dire l'inquiétude on entendait pas de de
sirène on on on pouvait pas imaginer ce
qui ILT arrêté le match oui oui à la
mi-temps les deux équipes ont préféré ne
pas reprendre et ça a été bien géré
parce que le speaker tout de suite a
annoncé restez bien là et ils ont
confiné les spectateurs au stade alors
justement quand vous êtes confiné vous
dites quoi parce que là moment là ça
commence le stade il commence à se dire
il se passe quelque chose de sérieux
quand même en fait quand Yelena m'a
envoyer les messages voilà moi j'étais
avec mon mari mon cousin et on s je
montrai les messages je dis qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on on y va on rentre et on se
dit non regarde on est en sécurité en
fait on se dit on est plus en sécurité
dans le stade ouais que dehors en fin de
compte ouais c'est c'est pas un pe c'est
pas c'est c'est c'est pas bête en voilà
et donc du coup voilà on a regardé la
première mi-temps mais vraiment sans
sans du tout penser à ce qui se passait
à l'extérieur et puis alors à la
mi-temps on a commencé un peu à essayer
de télécharger les vidéos à téléphoner à
gauche à droite puis on a vu que le
match ne reprenait pas là le speaker a
parlé et donc euh vous êtes resté
combien de temps dans le stade oh euh le
match commençait à 20h45 et on a après
après le après l'arrêt du match vous
êtes resté combien de temps en fait ils
ont évacué tribune par tribune nous on
était tribune 1 donc on a plus on a pu
évacuer les premiers on est on a pu
sortir du mal du stade à 23h40 ah ouais
quand même quand même et donc vous êtes
resté très longtemps dans le stade sans
match en fait à à attendreou très mais
très calme vraiment les gens discutaient
les gens se disaient mais les gens doent
être sur leur téléphone sur leur truc ou
des pr av app vous dire quoi dit quoi ne
sors pas alors moi je lui disais moi je
lui disais voilà quand je serai dans la
voiture je t'envoie un message quand on
est sur le le ring de Bruxelles je
t'envoie un message parce que c'est vrai
que on savait pas trop à quelle heure on
allait pouvoir quitter si on pouvait
quitter allez je veux dire de quelle
manière on pourrait quitter et donc
voilà je lui avais dit que je la
tiendrai au courant et vous avez eu peur
pour votre fille ou non mais je la
sentais stressée quand même bien sûr bah
oui c'est normal qu'elle soit stressée
vous avez pu dormir tu as pu dormir
cette nuit ou pas c'est pas vraiment
j'ai plus dormi cet après-midi que ouais
cette nuit tu étais tu étais stressé
c'est normal oui non j'ai tu as eu peur
pour tes parents oui j'ai eu peur je me
suis dit s'il le retrouve ça va aura un
petit peu moins de stress mais et en
plus là c'est vrai parce que vous avez
passé quand même toute une nuit avec un
tueur donc qui se baladait dans la ville
vous aviez pas de nouvelles est-ce que
c'est vrai que est-ce que vous avez pas
suivi toute la nuit pour savoir si il
avait été interpellé ou pas
alors moi c'est vrai qu'en me réveillant
je la première chose que je fais c'est
mettre les infos c'est vrai et votre
mari il était stressé ou pas du tout bah
je vous avoue que on était au lit à 2h
du matin donc on a essayé de dormir un
petit peu quand même récupérer et et
voilà on a quand même allumé les infos
le matin
et j'ai pas l'impression que vous vous
soyez très stressé c'est ça qui est qui
est fou et c'est vrai que voilà donc et
c'est et à mon avis c'est voilà vous
étiez j'ai l'impression voilà que c'est
et vous avez géré le stress et que le
stress était très bien géré dans le dans
le stade oui les autorités ont bien géré
et elles ont demandé aux spectateurs
supporters suédois de rester le plus
tard et les ont raccompagné après soit à
l'aéroport soit à leur hôtel parce que
voilà en enlevant le maillot pour ne pas
être cononnu parce que le tueur les
autorités le savaient avait ciblé deux
suédois déjà suéois